foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists coming up today on this free
public minimal episode of course we're
joined by malabama hi everybody CK
Coleman It's the Most Wonderful Time of
the Year it is December now wow yeah man
we're finally doing it yeah well it's
that time of year where we're talking
about leaving our towns traveling
somewhere but this is really an
evergreen episode we got the rest of our
team here in the studio as well we're
today we're talking about intentional
travel and what does that mean for you
we also have an outstanding lightning
round segment a live stream question a
great listener tip for you you can check
out the full two and a half hour maximal
edition of episode 369 where we answer
four times the questions and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
that private podcast episode is
available right now at patreon.com the
minimalists your support keeps our
podcasts and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say with me
y'all advertisements suck let's start
with our callers if you have a question
or comment for our podcast give us a
call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at
theminimalists.com our first question
question today is from renetta hi this
is renetta and I'm a patreon subscriber
calling from Denmark my question is for
TK on the recent stuffitis episode you
mentioned that you usually travel with a
book bag but that the last time you
travel by plane you didn't even bring a
backpack do you usually travel for
overnight or multiple late trips with
just a backpack can you walk us through
your packing list or tips to minimize
what we travel with
TK I want to get to you with this
question because I know it's addressed
specifically for you but joining us on
the phone to help us answer this
question if someone I would call a
travel expert a friend of ours his name
is Malcolm fontier and you'll probably
know him from packed bags Malcolm thank
you so much for joining us today
thanks for having me here
it's good to be here so he's joining us
from Montana uh up in Bozeman where
packed bags his travel bag company is
located and you may know about packed
bags because five years ago shortly
after our first Netflix documentary came
out minimalism which by the way you can
still check out no longer on Netflix
we've removed it from Netflix you can
still check it out though at
minimalismfilm.com there's a scene in
minimalism where uh Ryan and I are
walking around all these different
bookstores airbnbs hotels Etc and I open
up my bag that is packed and
I am showing off what I travel with what
is in the minimalists bag even though
Ryan and I are on this tour for an
entire year all I have is this one
carry-on piece of luggage that It just
fits in our trunk Ryan's Toyota Corolla
Ryan had the same exact bag soda Colin
right in the documentary right yeah and
so as we're traveling around with bag I
started on packet and so many people
started reaching out and saying where'd
you get the bag and at first I was so
upset like this is this is what you got
out of our minimalism documentary is
where can I buy your bag I'm like I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry that that's the one
thing that you're reaching out to me
about on Twitter
I realized like well no I've gotten more
value from this bag than just about any
other material possession that I own I
use it every single day when we're
traveling whether it's a short if I'm
going out for a day or if I'm going out
for a year I'm packing one bag and it
fit everything that I needed it created
some limitations so that I couldn't over
pack it made me be really intentional
with my travel and I said well you know
sorry only 300 of these bags were ever
made our friend Malcolm plantier made it
and it's not available anymore and
eventually Malcolm you reached out to us
and said hey would you like to partner
up on bringing this bag back out because
so many people are asking for it and
it's the one and only time Ryan and I
have ever endorsed a physical good or
product we've ever made a physical good
or product and as you know we don't do
any advertisements on this podcast well
he teamed up with Malcolm and our sales
strategy was hey you probably don't need
a new bag but if you do here is the one
that has worked really well for us yeah
and so that's our backstory with Malcolm
that was five years ago that we
partnered with him to launch that bag
and he's turned that into an entire
company now uh packed is the name of the
company they have different travel bags
for intentional travel Malcolm I want to
address renetta's question head on
though
um well we'll ask TK because he's
specifically mentioned something but I'd
like to know about you when you travel
how do you travel intentionally
absolutely
um that was a great uh great recap that
Josh I just want to add one piece of uh
information uh for the for anybody out
there listening if my memory is correct
I think what you were showing in that
piece in the in the movie was how you
keep your clean underwear separate from
your dirty underwear
I'm not mistaken anybody out there
struggles with that Josh has a great
strategy and uh I recommend going and
checking out that piece of the movie
um but yeah yeah back to Renata's
question
um yeah for me uh there's a few
different things
um one uh I guess is
we're all guilty I think of if you have
the space build a space and um and so uh
if you have an oversized bag it just it
tempts you to throw in that one extra
thing like I don't know if I really need
that extra that extra pair of pants or a
shirt or shoes but I got the space so
I'll just throw it in there
um so step one is just you know
traveling with something that you know
is realistic as far as I can fit what I
need in here and no more because uh for
me you always it feels like one more
pair of whatever
um but halfway through that trip
especially if you're spending a lot of
time on your feet you start regretting
that that extra weight there
um that's one way
for sure so TK what's your secret to
traveling with one backpack oh there's
no secret man there was just an
experiment I was just so overwhelmed by
having so many things and I didn't like
the burden of it I didn't like the
physical heaviness of it I didn't like
the the way it was just consuming you
know mental real estate and so I just
said I'm gonna try to get away without
it now what I used to do is in my book
bag I would have my laptop and my
charger I would have about three to four
portable phone chargers
um I would have food in there like some
protein bars and some fruit I would have
about like three books and and probably
some other stuff that I'm that I'm
forgetting and what I realized was I'm
packing everything based on fear I'm
afraid that some emergency is going to
come up with work and I'll need my
laptop and then I'm afraid that while
I'm using my laptop my battery's gonna
die so I need that big charger that I
don't like carrying around I'm afraid
that I'm gonna really need my phone and
my phone battery is gonna die and one
portable charger won't be enough so I
have three or four portable chargers I'm
afraid that I'm gonna get hungry and I
won't have anything to eat so I got to
make sure I have some protein bars and
some fruit in there and I realized what
if I just
let go of all those fears and just trust
it myself to make things work maybe I
won't succeed but at least I can give
myself a try right and so I said I'm not
going to bring my computer because
everything I do on there I can do on my
phone and not only that I'm lying to
myself because I don't have time to do a
bunch of work anyways right so let's
just admit that let's just own that
let's stop pretending like I'm gonna do
some stuff and that actually made my
life less stressful because I stopped
making promises to other people that
I'll do this or that on the road and I
just started getting honest and saying
I'll handle that when I come back I'm
going to be on the road I won't be doing
any work right and so I just boil it
down to my computer I mean to my phone
and then I say well I don't need all
those Chargers I will just bring my one
charger that goes into the wall and I'll
put that in my pocket and what I'll do
is I'll turn my phone off when I'm not
using it and I'll choose not to use it
less so that the battery I mean not to
use it as much so that the battery lasts
longer so now I get on the plane and I
don't use my phone for texting for
looking at the internet I don't pay
money to be online while I'm on the
plane I don't use my phone to read
anything that's on there I just turn it
off and I give myself a break from the
phone and you know what I do I just sit
there and sometimes when I sit there I
enjoy meditating or my body says gee
thank you I'm going to sleep right and I
fall asleep and the same thing with the
books I'll bring like three or four
books because I'm afraid that I'm gonna
get bored or I'm gonna I'm afraid that
I'll pick the wrong book and I just
leave them all at home and it's like hey
you know what I didn't have time to read
anyway you know and and I can kind of
get to know my own mind and so I just
did away with the bag
and I not only felt lighter and felt
Freer but then I just saw through all of
my fears and realized that most of the
stuff that I'm packing I don't need it
anyway and so I'm not against bringing a
bag I can imagine some scenarios where
it might be useful to bring but every
time I travel now I question that and I
and I just think about hey what what am
I comfortable holding in my hand and
putting in my pocket and it just feels
good to go that way and I I still feel
like people look at me like what rule
did I break to do that because
everyone's just like so overburdened
with their stuff and they're like what
is this guy doing I mean and sometimes
if I have a layover I try to get
non-stops but there have even been times
where I'll have an hour and a half
layover which is not a lot and I'll just
leave the airport and go for a walk
because not having any stop I don't have
any fear about getting back in I'm never
in a rush to catch that plane it's just
amazing to be able to do that you know
man it's so nice to have only a carry-on
I mean and this is I mean I I guess
maybe it is a little bit of a promotion
but like that's what I like about
Malcolm's bags is like all of the them
fit as a carry-on so like you don't have
to worry about putting it in the little
measurement thing and seeing if it's
gonna you know meet the requirements to
be carry on but like I'm telling you
like that has freed up me and Mariah so
much like what stood out to me TK is the
the multiple charges because what you
had there were some just in case items
yeah and you know when Josh and I we
when we went on our first tour
um we brought a bunch of just in case
items with us I mean we we uh it was
only a week that we were gone for that
first uh leg that we did with uh
minimalism live a meaningful life with
that book and uh we get to our
destination we get to our hotel in St
Petersburg Florida we open up the trunk
and I start looking at everything we
have and I'm like dude we are the
biggest Hypocrites because I've got a
duffel bag I've got a suitcase Josh has
like a garment bag in case there was
like an impromptu funeral or wedding I
have no idea why he brought the garment
bag I think he was thinking about
wearing a suit during one of the events
impromptu wedding yeah right I was
hoping Nicodemus would die during the
tour
one of the biggest rules that I have
right now is I don't carry uh two of
anything that isn't necessary so of
course with shirts I'm gonna carry
multiple shirts so I can get by for a
few days
um if I want to bring pants I just bring
the one pair of pants that I have
um if I plan on swimming I'll bring a
pair of shorts but I don't bring
multiple pairs of shorts where that's
what I was doing when we went down to St
Pete I'm like well we're going to be in
Florida maybe we'll go swimming so I'll
bring a pair of swim trunks and then
like Malcolm said I've got room for
another pair I might as well bring
another pair with me just in case that
one pair gets shredded or too dirty and
I want to swim you know twice but now
like yeah I I pack enough clothes
basically for about five days and what
happens like uh Mariah and I just went
Upstate New York to visit some of my
family and I brought five days worth of
clothes we were there for 10 days and
yeah on that day five or day six we did
some laundry it wasn't that big of a
deal and like everywhere we went on tour
in 2014 there was always a place to do
laundry so in 2014 we kind of learned
from our past mistakes and we brought
only that bag that that Josh was talking
about I'll never forget when that cop
pulled us over
so we get pulled over for going one mile
over the speed limit in Kansas and uh
the cop basically is like well Josh I
can uh I can either uh give you a
speeding ticket or you can let me search
your car like that was the ultimatum he
gave us so Josh is like okay you can
search our car and like we go off to
this side of the road and Josh is like
hey Ryan do I need to worry about
anything in there man
I'm like no Josh thankfully Malcolm's
bags have these hidden Pockets right
exactly we're good to go so so this so
This dude opens up the trunk and he sees
two bags in there and he's like what are
you guys doing and we're like oh we're
on a 100 City book tour he's like how
long have you been on the road oh we've
been on the road for like four or five
months and he's like all you have is
this one bag each like it was he was
real it was real sus to him and I mean
what are we gonna say officer were
minimalists
Malcolm I'd love to bring him
a point that TK said when it was in
there about sometimes people look at you
specifically that you don't have
um I've been in that same spot coming
back through customs on time on an
international trip and uh you know
Customs uh Customs agents are constantly
looking for a way to you know something
to something that like tipped them off
and when I came through to just one uh
shoulder bag they're like you're coming
back from an international trip and
that's all you have you don't have any
more luggage you need to collect oh wow
no I'm sorry like if you try traveling
we just carry on and and these rolled
his eyes at me and let me go through but
um but a couple of things that Ryan and
TK said uh totally resonate with me one
is um is uh is is versatility in helping
narrow down your stuff is um you know
like TK's example of the Chargers uh and
uh Ryan's talking about some of the the
clothes and stuff for me it's like yeah
when you look at you know trying to pick
things that are super versatile like
whether it's a pair of shoes that you
know I could hike in these or or I can
go to uh somewhat nice restaurant in
them if I can get one pair of shoes that
is good doing all those things that's
the winner
um yeah and um yeah and you know the and
the other yeah it's just uh is is that
just being is I think it's for me
traveling and part of the travel
experience is all about improvising I
mean that's part of that's part of what
the the experience is and it makes you
come back with memories
um you know when when I'm at home that's
the time when you've got everything in
its place where you're like oh I need to
do this and you grab that off the shelf
uh when you're traveling uh for me it's
like all right it's about making do it's
about figuring out how to get through
the situation and uh and you know and
when you do that with your travel gear
if you've got just enough to get by but
you know a little creativity you can
make it work uh to do everything you
need to and that's to me that's part of
that travel experience I love it like
yeah making an experience out of maybe
hunting down something that that you
forgot or that you need
um the other thing too is like you can't
plan for everything especially when you
go internationally so as much you could
bring all the bags you want this is
going to be something that comes up yeah
what TK was talking about earlier and
what both of you and Malcolm have
alluded to is something uh I I call the
go without it Rule and this is an
extension of the just in case rule that
Ryan just talked about the just in case
rule is if I'm going to pack something
just in case no don't pack it at all
because if I absolutely need it I can
replace it for less than twenty dollars
in less than 20 minutes from wherever we
are and most people don't know that that
started as that travel Rule and then we
brought it into our homes because it
made so much sense for the excess in our
homes as well the go without it rules an
extension of that where it's like hey
you know what I'm going to bring these
four books wait a minute
I know that I might read some of them
but just because I could I could read
all of them doesn't mean that I'll get
more value by bringing them than if I
were to go without if I go without I'll
actually get more value so instead of
bringing all four books I bring one book
generally I'll read that book until it's
finished and guess what there's no book
shortage wherever I go to a city and
it's like oh where am I possible gonna
find a second book to read no they're
really easy to find books right now of
course you can do it from your phone you
can do it from a Kindle as well so
you're not weighing yourself down I tend
to prefer physical books whenever
possible and so I will simply go without
the extra three I'll bring the one like
you do with your shorts I'll bring the
one book I'll simply go without the
excess because if I need to go out and
get something I definitely can do it
Renata before we go it's probably worth
mentioning this is just echoing
everything that Malcolm TK and Ryan have
said travel with fewer things creates
room for more experiences now the way
that we do that is we create these
limitations we can't pack everything
just like we can't experience everything
as well and so limiting our travel plans
our travel packing
traveling with fewer things opens up the
possibilities for us and the only way we
do that is we create these rules that
work well for us and so if you haven't
done so already I'd encourage you to
download our free ebook it's called the
minimalist rulebook 16 rules for living
with less most of those you can apply to
your travels as well or if you want the
audiobook version renetta we'd be happy
to send that to you as well Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for the lightning round where we
answer your questions from Tick Tock
that's right you can follow the
minimalist on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
now during the lightning round TK this
is where we each have 60 seconds to
answer your questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we call the minimal maxims we
put these minimal maxims in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media you can
find all of those show notes over at the
minimalists.com podcast or we deliver
them right to your in box as well if you
go to the minimalist.com just give us
your email address we'll never send you
spam we'll never send you junk we'll
never send you advertisements because
advertisements suck but we will send you
our weekly show notes and our simple
newsletter each week as well we have a
question here from Tick Tock coyote swap
has something for us how do I get over
the fomo with new experiences I don't
want to feel like I'll waste my time or
money if I don't end up enjoying a trip
or an activity let's start 60 seconds on
the clock for Ryan Nicodemus The Greek
Freak himself
I love that let's go all right uh here's
my pithy answer for you living in the
moment is the antidote to the fear of
missing out and if you want to make that
a little bit more pithier you could say
limo kills fomo so here's the thing is
when you decide to do something you're
doing that one thing and you're missing
out on everything else and if you are
sitting there torturing yourself
thinking about all the things you're
missing out on then you're missing where
you are in that moment I love the fact
that we are joyous already you are
joyous where you are right now and you
can bring that Joy wherever you go and
if you choose to live in the moment with
that Joy well then you won't be missing
out on anything oh he did it in under a
minute
nice let's see what you got you can have
my 18 seconds
oh that's like Freestyle here son you
can have my extra 18 seconds
and he just used it
it was worth it was worth it all right
um
every destination is desirable when
decision making is a process of
discovery the process of making choices
is not a school test where you have to
prove to someone how smart you are or
where you have to give the one correct
answer the purpose of making a choice is
to create experiences that lead to the
discovery of new possibilities and to
the discovery of interesting things
about yourself that ultimately move you
closer to putting together life the way
you want to live it ah that doesn't make
sense TK I'm trying to make decisions
because I want to make money your
decision Theory doesn't work for me
because what does discovering something
new have to do with making money well
wouldn't it benefit you if you knew how
to make more money yeah of course it
would so what if you made decisions that
didn't come with the pressure of this
has to profit me right away and you made
decisions with the mindset of I just
need to learn something that's going to
move me a step closer to my goals when
you make decisions that way
stress-free
CK calls my time one minute two seconds
thank God you had my extra time you
almost got the Buzzard here Josh you can
have my 16.
that's why I hear Josh let me take two
of yours
you know what uh let's talk about the
fear of missing out um
what is the fear of missing out it's
really just worrying what is a worrier a
worrier is a person who concerns
themselves with outcomes that are
outside their control
so sometimes I'll get concerned about
something that's within my control that
concern is really useful because it
allows me to go One Direction or another
to avoid a terrible outcome right
but there are other things that are
outside of my control that I can't do
anything about except worry about those
things and the more I worry about them
the greater my fear I start fearing
everything and so if you want to avoid
the fear of missing out it's about
understanding what is within your
control
you can't do everything and so what you
can control is what you do right now
what is within your area of concern and
if you understand that you can let go of
the worry altogether
59.48
um that brother is efficient let's check
in with our patreon a live stream here
in a second but first real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist actually I got two things for
you one is the this new YouTube series
that Professor Sean and I have been
working on it's called terrible words
then the tagline is don't use these
words in your writing
and so if anyone who is an aspiring
writer wants some free writing tips how
to write better has a channel you can
find a youtube.com how to write better
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well and you can check out the
four videos in this new terrible words
Series where I just give you a four
minute lesson about certain words that
you might not want to use in your
writing and why you don't want to use
those and how you can use a different
kind of word to radically improve your
writing is it four words for four videos
yes okay I was gonna ask for one of the
words but no spoilers yeah no spoilers
you have to check out the whole the
whole series think about Charles Barkley
voice over that's a terrible word
oh man I didn't realize Charles Barkley
was in the studio
[Laughter]
well one other thing uh to mention real
quick is our added value segment we're
moving that over to the private podcast
just because we're doing something a
little bit different now so this is for
our right here right now segment we've
been doing a lot more about physical
Goods uh this week in fact we have three
travel items that I will never travel
without and so we'll talk about that on
the private podcast you can check that
out during the added value segment at
the end of that let's check in with the
patreon live stream malabama who has a
question for us here's a question from
Lindsay she says I visit my family a few
times a year and often pay for meals and
go shopping while I'm there how do I
make a budget for this would this go
under my normal food budget gifts
because I'm paying for my family's whole
dinner or bundle it just as vacations
um so I keep a monthly budget Mariah and
I do and for things like this like if I
buy someone uh some coffee or buy them a
meal or whatever it is I'd usually put
it under gift giving but you know here's
a little here's a little trick to the
budget you always I always have a little
wiggle room with a little miscellaneous
category yeah for these unexpected
expenses or these not normal expenses so
if I have money in the gift giving I'll
put them in there if not I'm a thumb out
I got that miscellaneous to kind of get
my back but uh those are those are my
those are my two categories that I keep
in there that I would
feel totally fine putting either of
those expenses under personally I put it
under travel uh but I think the key what
you're saying is whatever you put it
under keep it there as part of your
budget the budgeting has some rigidity
built into it so you're not living
beyond your means exactly and if I am
out of money on either of those
categories and guess what it's not in
the budget I had someone reach out to me
um via email very kind person hey man
come to this conference you know it's
like an 800 ticket we'll you know you
and your wife can come and we'll give
you free tickets I'm like okay cool like
um be happy to come down there
um is there any are you like including
hotel and stuff with this because uh
really not in the budget right now no
unfortunately uh you know it's just the
ticket I'm like okay great generous
offer but that's not on our travel
budget right now so we won't be able to
attend I like that
good for your budget not for mine that's
right that's right all right before we
get to our listener tips today coming up
on the maximal episode this week we have
a million more questions from callers
social media and the live stream a
private minimalist home tour we've got
our obsolete object segment and
everyone's favorite TK's tweet of the
week yes and much much more of less if
you wanna hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast at
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description malabama what
else you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners hi my
name is Emma um I'm from Fresno
California I just wanted to leave a
comment for listeners
um but I tried to do minimalism I
noticed that as a woman I have so many
products
um as far as makeup lotion perfumes
makeup remover
um and just a lot of bathroom products
so I looked into more natural ways to
get more function out of products and I
went ahead and switched over to using
coconut oil which can be used to
or basically any products that I had I
was able to replace it with coconut oil
and I went ahead and just threw away a
bunch of the products I had and it
really minimized the amount of clutter I
had under my sink in my bathroom which
was really freeing so just wanted to
show that tip thanks
all right y'all that is our minimal
episode for today we'll see you over on
patreon for the full two and a half hour
maximal edition of episode 369. oh by
the way big thanks to Malcolm fontier
for joining us today you can check out
packed bags I'll put a link to that in
the show notes but of course as we
always say you won't be more complete by
buying a new thing so you probably don't
need another bag yes it's added immense
value to our lives but we're not trying
to pawn something else on you you are
complete without it if you leave here
today with just one message let it be
this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you foreign